[music]
>> I'm aware
that especially if you're living in a
non-Muslim country like the one I'm
living in.
People are afraid
that if I might feel that Muslim, I'll
be targeted. In fact, this beard, this
cap, it does wonders. It opens the doors
for me for the hour.
And I told you yesterday when I travel
in the plane to the Western countries,
they ask, "What is this cap you're
wearing?" This cap.
It starts.
I'm a Muslim.
And then I can ask a counter question,
"Are you a Christian?"
If so, which church you belong to? The
conversation starts. And if someone
looking and smiling at me,
I ask, "Are you smiling at my cap?
I'm a Muslim."
Start the conversation.
Open the doors.
Imagine
if suppose
you are going in a bus
or in a train.
If you're going in a bus
and there is a Muslim girl wearing hijab
and if someone wants to
tease that girl
if that person sees
four five men
with cap and beard sitting in the bus
he'll think a million time before
teasing that Muslim girl, right or
wrong?
If I do something these five people will
bounce on me.
Those five people may be old people,
maybe feeble.
This cap
it can't even hurt a fly.
I never tried and the fly swatter but I
think it can't even hurt a fly.
This cap but it does wonders.
Our beloved prophet Muhammad said
he told for the Eid in Salah, it's
mentioned in Bukhari, for the Eid in
Salah he told all the women including
the menstruating women
and the women who have not reached of
age
they should go to the Eidgah
even if they don't have to offer Salah.
Why?
What is the logic behind that? Even if
you don't have to offer Salah, go to the
Eidgah.
Imagine if there are three four
villages.
When you go for Eid Salah you normally
have the sunnah to go in open ground.
For four five villages you find about
30,000 people coming. So 30,000 Muslims.
Number one, it boosts up our morale.
30,000 Muslims living in these three
four villages.
To the enemies of Islam, oh 30,000
Muslims.
They will think 100 time before
interfering.
If the label shows your intent, wear it.
You should see this talk of mine. It's
mainly discussing on these three things
only.
The beard
the cap
and the toes above the ankle.
And
let me tell you frankly, I don't want to
mince words.
Wearing trousers above the ankle does
look like a joker. Maybe they look good.
But I've got no problem with this
trousers above the ankle.
I meet the pauper, I meet the king. I've
met presidents of countries, I've met
prime ministers of countries, I've met
chief ministers. No problem. I've gone
to European countries, I've gone to
Western countries, gone to the best of
the hotels, to the best of palaces. This
is my identity.
Cap, wearing trousers.
Yet they invite me.
When Raj Kapoor, you know, Raj Kapoor is
a very famous hero, old-time hero of the
Bollywood.
Raj Kapoor. His fashion was to wear
trousers above the ankle, and most of
the people want to follow him. When Raj
Kapoor wears that, everyone wants to
follow, it's in vogue. That means if you
keep trousers above the ankle, you are
in vogue.
You know how you have now in the Western
world, you wear the Bermuda shorts.
Bermuda is called 3/4 3/4, Bermuda, no?
3/4. Vogue. So, when it comes in vogue,
you want to wear
a prophet did it 1,400 years back, and
you don't want to follow?
So, they say either below the ankle
or like Ibn Abbas, clear.
In between one to five.
See, anything that gets in vogue,
you don't follow
the vogue. You create a vogue.
YOU BE A VOGUE MAKER.
You should be a trendsetter.
Don't follow a trend if it's against
Quran and Sunnah. If it's for Quran and
Sunnah, follow it. And you create a
trend.
In our school, we have programmed
trendsetters.
We create the trend.
If you have the ability,
if you follow the Quran and Sunnah with
the nature, with the character, with the
kindness, with the class.
All these things, good or bad, are
immaterial.
The best of the people in the world will
invite you.
See, even the Sikhs
Sikhs are the people in India. They're
hardly 2.9% of the Indians.
They always wear their turban.
And I really appreciate them.
Even when they go to the army, when I
had gone to Canada in 1996,
it came in the front page of one of the
Sikhs
filed a case against the government. I
want to wear my turban in the army. And
they had to allow him.
In a cricket match, if they have to show
an Indian,
they will show a sardarji, a Sikh,
wearing a turban in the army.
He's proud of his identity. So, why are
we Muslims?
Why we afraid to identify ourselves as
Muslims?
Why are we afraid?
This is our label.
We have to wear it, and we have to be
proud of it.
And believe me, it does wonders.
And
I'm aware that so-called modern
Muslims
would say, "What is this? Wearing the
pajama of your younger brother and
wearing the kurta of your elder
brother."
There's a saying that you're wearing a
trouser of your younger brother
and wearing the top of your elder
brother.
So, following the sunnah is an important
and then
you do it
when others are not doing it.
Like, if you do it in Saudi Arabia, it's
common.
So, whether Ibrahim Zirani does it,
alhamdulillah.
Common, most of the people
most of majority
less. So, now it's changing or not? But
most of the people, masha Allah, they
are above the ankle.
So, for him, it's not much of a test.
But if you're living in a non-Muslim
country, or living in a Muslim country
who doesn't agree that this is the
sunnah or this is a requirement, that's
a challenge.
So, if you do it in a country where it's
a challenge, and if you do it, insha
Allah, you'll get multiple times more
Sabah.
And you'll have multiple times more
opportunity to do Dawah.
It can open doors
and easily identify.
And for me, there are other benefits.
I wear this white cap, so non-Muslim
You are the same
You are the same speaker coming on the
TV.
You are the same orator.
You speak so
I entity. And normally on the
television, if they're surfing channels
are non-Muslims
They see a person wearing a tie and a
suit and then wearing a kufi
wearing a cap and a beard looks like a
joker. So, the people
they are curious. Now, who is this
person? Joker?
If they think I'm a joker and hearing my
speech, I want to be a joker.
Because it's not going against Quran and
Sunnah.
Oh, this person is quoting the Bible.
Who is quoting the Hindu scriptures?
Let's listen to him.
And the same thing, imagine
if you see a person wearing a tika
and a saffron cloth and reciting the
Quran, what will you do?
What will you do with that
Of course, I will stop and want to watch
it. Yeah, of course.
>> were watching Zakir Naik, you'll change
the channel. No. Zakir goes tonight.
It's correct, correct, right or wrong?
Absolutely.
>> Absolutely. You'll say, "I want to see
who is this saffron
pandit coming with a tika and reciting
the Quran?"
Zakir goes to the office.
Maybe you have Zakir in the office and
television. Let's see.
So, if that thing can shift you from
Zakir Naik, that means it's a powerful
thing, correct?
The same way
if you wear the cap and a beard, it's a
key
initiation.
And when you open your mouth and you're
speaking fluent English and you're
speaking reason, you're speaking logic
and you're quoting the scriptures
you are winning over the hearts and they
have that preconceived
idea
that Muslims are typical stereotypes.
Muslims are terrorists. We deal with
that in the question answer session.
So, if you know all those answers,
you can say, "I'm a Shiite and I'm not a
terrorist."
You know, there's a movie, "I'm Khan and
I'm not a terrorist."
The thing is that use the best of your
ability. But, the main thing we're doing
is for something.
Further, it is a commandment of our
beloved Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam. It becomes further on
us and we do it. We love him
and we revere him. We obey him. We
follow him and we get the help of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. When we get the help
of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
the doors open.
And I've told you the day before
yesterday and even on the first day that
all success is only and only with the
help of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. Surah
Al Imran, chapter 3, verse 160. If Allah
helps you, none can overcome you. If
Allah forsakes you, who is there then
who can help you? So, let the believers
put their trust in Allah. And if Allah
removes this
support,
class.
So, only way you can be an effective die
is with the help of Allah. Only way you
can be better than Zakir Naik is with
the help of Allah.
And always pray to Allah that let your
help and your mercy
keep on flowing towards me.
If he removes it,
even for a moment,
and I'll give you the example
day before yesterday.
It's a disaster.
Even those who argue, I know many
Westerners
and many Muslims when they go to Western
country, "Oh,
in Medina,
it's different. Mecca is different. Now,
I'm in Makki age. And what is the use of
keeping trousers above the ankle?"
I mean, does it hurt anyone if you keep
trousers above the ankle?
Are you hurting anyone?
You may be saving a couple of dollars on
the cloth, inshallah.
I know it looks like a joker.
But, if you're doing it for the love of
your prophet,
for the sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
inshallah, success will be yours, and
people will listen to you with
more attentiveness.
And inshallah, inshallah, you'll be a
more effective guy.
That's the reason these three things are
very important, and we have a short
break here.
It's already called to 11. We are half
an hour
Yeah, so we'll have a half an hour
break, inshallah, and we will come back
inshallah at 11:15 sharp for the second
session, that's the continuation of the
techniques of giving Islamic talks. Wa
akhiro da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin.
>> [music]
[music]